tras el llamamiento anoche de Jair
bolsonaro Los camioneros se empiezan a
liberar las carreteras del país hoy la
Policía Federal de carreteras se
informaba que hay menos de 80 bloqueos
en tan solo siete estados Eso sí la mano
dura de la justicia ha bajado sobre esa
categoría hay al menos 37 camioneros
arrestados y se han impuesto multas
4.200 por un valor de 3,5 millones de
dólares poco a poco Brasil le recupera
la normalidad tras las elecciones y
mientras tanto el equipo de gobierno de
luna liderado por el vicepre geraldo
alzhemian trabaja todo vapor para
conseguir una transición eficiente y
serena hoy admin se ha reunido con el
responsable de los presupuestos del año
que viene para ver hasta qué punto es
posible mantener las promesas de campaña
por ejemplo mantener el subsidio de 600
reales 137 dólares concedido por
bolsonaro en año electoral recuperar la
inversión en la farmacia popular que
había sido mermada por los recortes del
gobierno de bolsonaro o adecuar el
sueldo de los funcionarios públicos a la
inflación queda mucho por delante Hasta
que el 1 de enero Lula pueda entrar en
su nuevo gobierno su tercer mandato
Mientras tanto habrá que ver si siguen
las protestas o si los ánimos se apaguen